I think I'm the only one who
disassociates myself in social
situations
like when I'm at work I do this thing
where I take off my classes and then
like since like my vision is already
blurry like it kind of like blurs my
head a little bit so like I'm seeing
stuff but I'm not like
I'm not like receiving it if that makes
sense since everything is blurry like I
I just don't think kind of my mind gets
blurred because I can't see anything so
like even though like I'm hearing stuff
and like I'm operating I'm basically on
autopilot and that's that's basically
what I do like all the time because
thinking thinking is hard
thinking it's hard that's that's all I
got I got nothing to add today am I the
only one who cries in the mirror and
then Smiles after I think it's more of a
trauma response for me it's very much a
I look at myself crying and then I try
to smile to make myself feel better so
yeah
am I the only one that secretly thinks
all my friends thinks I'm annoying
um and they're just trying to be nice so
they're friends with me
um I've always had this fear that people
don't really like me and they think I'm
annoying or they're just friends with me
because you know it's convenient it's
kind of like a fear if I call it out and
it's true then I'm just gonna hurt my
own feelings you know but uh I've been
friends with them for a long time so
some days I feel like this but some days
I feel like I genuinely have good
friends
I would say my answer will probably be
am I the only one that feels this way
like an alien am I the only one who's
alone on their birthday
am I the only one who practices how to
write with the opposite hand and because
that break my abdominant hand am I the
only one who
plucks their armpit hair
am I the only one who dances alone naked
am I the only one who hears what you're
thinking right now
you hear what I'm thinking
wait are we I thought it was it I
thought that was it
wait you got freaked out
am I the only one that wants to backhand
everyone
because they're annoying so when was the
last time you wanted to backhand someone
the minutes ago back up
am I the only one that takes in all the
straight caps
am I the only one in the world who likes
to sniff cat paws
what what do they smell like I don't
know they're kind of like cozy cozy paws
like it smells like Comfort I don't know
it's really weird
am I the only one who thought of a way
to put lotion on your back by yourself
I've been thinking about this for
probably since I was 19. I wonder have
any I don't see it nowhere that I don't
see it anywhere so I really don't think
that anyone has ever thought about that
because to this day to this day right
now there should be something in Walmart
that
you should be able to use to put lotion
on your back by yourself
am I the only one that Google's big
words before I like text it or say it
just in case I use it wrong
I don't like be typing and I'd be like
typing my sentence and the big word will
come up and I'll be like I know I'm
using it right I know I'm using it right
but I'm like just just make sure I hope
my friends doesn't think I'm taking too
long on time I'll go Google the word and
it's like okay that makes sense that I
go back and I have to make sure I smell
it right too because I don't sound
stupid
am I the only one who is always looking
for trash cans I never see trash cans
does anyone ever see trash cans I'm
always looking around I just never see
them anywhere you know I just feel like
that's something that we need to have
more of it's just trash cans so I don't
know I just am I the only one who thinks
about that
am I the only one that
ever puts their kids to bed at 7 30 p.m
so this is your son this is my son can
you remember do you mind if I ask you do
you remember her putting you to bed at 7
30. yeah how did it feel it was annoying
it wasn't the best am I the only one who
hates being the first person
to start the toilet paper roll in the
porta potty where you'd be the first one
to start the toilet paper roll and then
would be all stuck to it and then
you trying to like you're like airpin
and you're trying to undo it and it's
like shredding and then you're like
am I the only one that deals with that
am I the only one that laughs uh when
I'm one of Keto bites me because I love
when it itches and I scratch my skin so
am I the only one
that going to the restroom is a waste of
time I feel like I'm the only person I I
don't like to go use the restroom and I
said I really have to because I feel
like I could be using my time and other
things am I the only one that takes
three hours to wake up and get ready in
the morning I wake up at like
five and then I don't head out to work
until 8 30. so three and a half hours
am I the only one who
um
like stocks
am I the only one who respects Miss
Piggy on a deep deep level
she's authentically herself she says
what she wants she takes no Gruff from
anybody and I would like to figure out
how to do that one day am I the only one
who brings my own comforter and sheets
wherever I travel because I don't like
sleeping on a hotel sheets and
comforters and I'm also only ones who
asked for plastic silhouette restaurants
because I don't like eating off the same
silverware as people before me even when
they watch them you know they just
throwing them in a pot of water and
they're not really scrubbing them so am
I the only one
am I the only one who struggles with
jealousy and
just fighting through that mentally
throughout like every day of just
just
a lot a lot throughout throughout um
through everyday life it's more so
leaning of why does my childhood trauma
lead me to have these jealousy and these
bad feelings that I just don't like
am I the only one who wants to know what
Deja Vu is and why it exists
it has to mean something and there has
to be common thread somewhere like if I
I'm not scientifically inspired or
talented but if I was I would devote my
life to figure out what it is and why it
exists so if anyone actually knows or
has a good theory or has heard something
from someone else
definitely drop in the comments it links
or or any any ideas that you have
because I would love to know me too I'm
behind the camera I want to know too uh
am I the only one who isn't too sure
about marriage because
um people change a lot and I don't want
to stay in something because I'm
familiar and comfortable
rather than because it's what I want
passionately why do you feel alone in
that
um because I feel like it's can be a
taboo
to be like non unmarried before like
once you're 30 or something because
people think what's
well not all people but I know that some
people look at people like oh why not
what's wrong with you I don't have to
commit to somebody forever to know that
I want them my life I don't want to be
in something that I'm I don't feel like
deeply passionately
soul on fire setting happy about
yeah you look at marriages and when
people are like so angry at each other
it's like what did that used to look
like you know why not just enjoy where
you're at momentarily if it's gonna be
forever it will be
you can't force anything to be together
just because you say it or you can't
force anything to be forever just
because you say it's forever you can but
then it's not a happy forever and what's
the point of being forever with that how
do you keep it going I don't know yet
find somebody new
wait so I don't know what happens with
you no maybe no
no I don't know I've just avoided
relationships for a while for a while
how old are you 29 I'll be 30 in October
okay
I haven't been in I haven't looked or
I've actually specifically avoided and
not looked for a relationship or to be
with anybody for the last three years or
so at night at Casey nap I'm like will
that be forever I don't think so but I
think it's a cute idea to think it is
you know
I love to think about it I love love I
love to think that it's real you know
but yeah but I don't want to ever get
myself in a place where
I like that idea of being with somebody
more like forever more than actually
being with them you know and being free
to feel comfortable enough to recognize
when it's not setting your soul on fire
anymore
you know and maybe I'm just a little too
scared
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next time
[Music]